okay call the house rules committee to
order and first thing on the agenda it's
2023 second all those in favor I those
opposed the eyes have it the second
issue is is the deadlines I believe you
all have a copy of the deadlines in
you make a motion to approve them or
discussion Senor
Weber
thank you Mr Speaker I just wanted to
raise for
discussion um I'm always the person who
is trying to get more time for the house
to deal with the House's bills because
we have so
many um and I I have sort of my usual
concern about the short time period to
report the house Bills going to a second
committee uh because that's just January
5th to the 15th and often the bills my
usual concern about that is that the
bills that uh are the biggest most
complicated and need to go to two
committees often come out late I assume
that's not going to be an issue this
time because we don't have a November
drafting period so I assume that we
would have all the bills in hand that
first week in
January uh but the other thing I was
thinking that we could pick up a little
more time if even if we didn't want to
move that one one week later is the
issues of the last day to report a house
bill not in the second committee which
is the huge bulk of our work um that
could be moved to march
2st with the last Daya act moved to
March 28th to give us a little more time
to work on that without destroying
anything else because this the second
committee bills will all be on their
way um so I just wanted to put that out
because I know that we will get to the
point next term where um you know I we
we literally last this last year had
about two weeks to get some of the
second committee bills out which was
really of concern because there wasn't
time for the first committee to do a
thorough um
review uh so I I would move all four of
those first deadlines February 25th 22nd
14th and 21st one week later but um
particularly the second committee ones
which are the the the ones not going to
a second committee which is the bulk of
our
work Mr clerk you Mr Speaker so the
difference in the first year and the
second year is that all builds have to
be introduced by theth January so that
comments
you
the next to start six weeks of of work
um regarding the the second committee uh
the not the second committee
um certainly do will dance
preference
sorry I wasn't on the mic sir okay
else s
man so if I understood correctly The
Proposal
28th question for the clerk does that
jam us up on anything that comes
after I I don't think so sir the the the
issue is that um uh the the following
week is the reporting of the early bills
uh the remaining house bills so I I
don't I don't see that that's an
issue the I would suggest um that
although that that becomes a session day
for sure uh that that shouldn't prohibit
us from meeting in session on the week
prior um as you all know uh we have been
doing more and more bills um on fewer
session days and uh I'm sure that your
families and your um dogs probably uh
don't like you being away as long as you
have been on those session days uh you
know we we do I I do think that we need
to be more timely in in the work coming
out of the Committees uh in order to
have more session days even if we do uh
Thursday afternoons rather than a full
day um if we have 25 bills that that we
should try to take up as much in session
as we can to to mitigate you know a
3-day 600 Bill
aside so if I'm correct we're going to
move
we're going to add the
28th if if you were ready for a motion I
would move that we change the deadline
which is March 14th for the last day to
report house bills not in a second
committee to March
21 and then move the March 28th deadline
March 20 current March 21st deadline to
the
28th um but I would say that I do agree
with the clerk that um that does require
some management of chairs and committees
to get stuff out um you know time was
before Co that we normally had a session
every single week on Thursday or
Wednesday or whichever day it was and
chairs no matter who who was in charge
were urged to get the bills out so that
those could uh get moved along but
um you know it's it's up to the
collective wisdom here I don't think I
don't think it's going to make a huge
difference either way but it was just
about
second
okay are you is are you just moving
those two dates or you moving the whole
just those two dat okay so we'll take up
that then we'll take up the full
calendar
favor
okay uh so now we need a motion to
accept the house
rules you already have
that okay the motion before us is there
any discussion on the anything else on
health
rules if
not uh all those in favor of adopting
house
rules oh you need to do a roll call L
will do a roll call Representative
Packard yes representative shirtliff yes
representative Smith yes representative
nter yes representative Osborne
yes represent Sweeney yes represent
willome yes represent Weber yes
representative Simpson yes motion is
uh late Drafting and induction of the
bills and the first one on the list is
representative
Davis
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to
all members of The Rules Committee for
allowing us to come in and make this
request
today uh the reason for a late filing uh
we've had meetings with new owners of
property in in Coos County in and
learned information that we didn't have
before uh it's potentially a a large
negative impact to Coos County and
possibly the rest of the
state um is pertaining to Timber taxes
so I don't know you know how much
information you need but that's the
reason basically we don't want too much
information we just need to know why the
uh the late filing you're asking for the
late filing yes for in we we've learned
new
information say something
yeah thank you Mr Speaker the we're
talking about the headwaters property in
Pittsburgh to start with it's 140,000
acres and uh it'll have a a as M
representative Davis said a a true
impact to start with in Kos County but
it'll be Statewide to do with u Timber
tax Recreation and U really our our
culture
so it's we need a little more time this
we've had meetings with them over the
last couple
weeks since the the filing deadline and
we really feel this is imperative to
continue on sen
Weber actually Mr Speaker I think you
just answered my question what I was
going to ask was the timing of when you
learned uh new information about this
situation and you said you had um
discussions over the last couple of
that is correct we've had uh
representative Davis myself had some
private meetings with the new land
owners and there was a public meeting
about 10 days ago and every time we meet
questions pres bosor thank you uh if
you're still in the process of gathering
new information are you even ready to
I believe so I uh we've been looking
into it we weren't ready to put in a
bill but in light of of new information
is I think something needs to be done
fairly
soon forther question thank you um and
so you would say that this is an an
emergency situation that cannot wait
so also this is a not a partisan piece
of legislation the whole County
delegation is involved with this and of
file okay we have a first and a second
discussion got to call the rooll on this
rooll uh the motion is for late Drafting
and in late drafting uh for
representative Davis representative
Packard yes representative shirtliff yes
represent Smith yes representative nter
yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes represent
willhelm yes represent Weber yes
representative Simpson yes U motion is
McGuire right thank you Mr
Speaker um my request is to be allowed
to violate house rule
36e which is the one that um prevents
you if a bill has been retained or or um
otherwise considered in the first year
to to allow it to be resubmitted in the
second year and the bill in question was
my own bill uh House Bill 593 I have I
brought a copy in case anybody wanted to
look at it um uh relative to the
forfeiture of Assets in connection with
the drug offense um which uh has to do
with RSA 318b col
17b and so uh what happened with this
bill was that it was um sent to the
criminal justice committee it had its
public well first of all we created the
bill and I did extensive work with the
Attorney General's office uh we met with
the representative of the Judiciary um
representative Lyn help me draft it Etc
um and also outside groups it's it's of
interest to the uh ACLU the AFP um
Institute for justice and so on um so we
did all that and we thought we had sort
of agreement among all those parties but
what we discovered in the public hearing
was the J Judiciary in particular was
not on board with this bill and so um
partly because of that and partly
because this is a complex bill
it was retained by the criminal justice
committee and so over the
summer um uh we met with the Chief
Justice and with um members of his staff
and discovered what the problem was with
them was had to do with the way the bill
didn't comport with their computer
system and and had the bill passed in
its original form it would have required
them to spend a lot of money on custom
software so we worked out way a way to
meet our policy goals but not cause that
problem to to to be compliant with the
way their software works and so you know
that took a fair amount of time and and
we worked out new language for the bill
and so I came to September when the
retain Bill committee you know the
committee was going to have its retained
Bill
hearing
and I could have just sort of dumped a
new 12-page Amendment or something on
them
but at in the meantime I had come up
with the idea of splitting the bill into
three pieces number one to make it
slightly more manageable number two to
make it more likely that certain pieces
would pass because there's objections to
part of the bill but not to the whole
bill you know
not there's a certain part of the bill
very small that that has considerable
objections um from law
enforcement um but I don't think that
applies to the bulk of the bill and and
also there
different the re reason we originally
had one bill was it all affects one RSA
this one small this one section but in
reality there's parts that are Financial
there's parts that have to do with
courtroom practice and there's parts
that have to do with state and federal
relations and so um it really in my mind
would be correct to have it as three
pieces and not as one big piece and it
would enhance the the we have to think
not just of passing the house but but of
you know passing and and uh being
enacted into law and I think it would
enhance at least some part of the bill
becoming law so
um and then the reason for um so that's
my request I so I asked the the criminal
justice committee please find this bill
um interim study they and this was my
plan and they agreed that that was
appropriate and so um I think that's
what's going to happen to House Bill 593
it's going to be interim
study um and then the question of well
why not just wait another year well this
bill involves Justice right this bill
involves um you know it's it's not a lot
of people um a lot of accused and so on
but it's some and so you know there's no
reason to wait um for you know for
justice to be done
basically thank
Weber I'm a little concerned about the
fact that a lot of this seems to be the
result of choices that were made with
respect to an existing Bill and a lot of
what you're arguing to us is that it
would be inappropriate to bring in
something large and cumbersome without
benefit of another hearing and I agree
with you entirely on that but there's no
reason why you couldn't have another
hearing now and get public input
particularly on amendment that would
have the pieces that you think are
particularly appropriate to go forward
but the rest of it sounds to me like
stuff that's been under consideration
for a very long time and is a matter of
tactics yes thank you for the question
representative when you say I'm I guess
I'm not quite sure when you say we could
have another public hearing now do you
mean the um subcommittee of Criminal
Justice that's dealing with this bill
could create the a new public hearing
Etc yes um with with if I may clarify it
could either be a subcommittee or it
could be a working uh session of the
full committee and all you have to do is
notice that
Amendment uh with reference to it in the
calendar so that's perfectly doable and
I think it's a laudable goal uh that
could be done within the existing
framework yes thank you um okay that
that is possible the the main the other
aspects of it in terms of timing are
that we worked extensively with a member
of the AG's office who has since um left
uh the AG and went into private practice
and so I would kind of like a little bit
of time to Circle back with them and get
uh new input on our on our
changes prior to showing them to the
legislature and so um the timing doesn't
quite work uh for that in my opinion um
and also I'm I'm
just I'm I'm enthusiastic
about breaking breaking up the bill um
because I think that make it easier both
on the legislature and on the members of
the public who are interested in certain
thing thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative just so I'm clear in my
own mind has the full committee met to
uh vote up and down on this bill as far
as I know
no follow up for the question would um
wouldn't it make more sense to go to
that committee when they do take it up
for their final disposition of the bill
uh to ask him to uh with the
recommendations you're going to make to
allow it to go forward yeah thank you
but
again I think the changes are more
substantial than the committee would
want to consider over this short period
of time that's that's the issue
um so so in my
opinion it's it's too put it's too
rushed because they're going to have to
weeks
man um two questions if that's allowed U
have they already EXA 593 or not the
subcommittee has with with my
recommendation of interim study and it
was unanimous but the but the full
committee has not thank you follow up
question the um so the three bills
you're proposing are they drafted
already yes I have them here okay
through o ol
no so you also want late drafting an
introduction yes I asked when I when I
asked to be on your agenda was during
the week of um uh where we were
submitting bills but and I asked should
I go to OS and have them say to me well
you can't P you know these are the same
as your other previous Bill and they and
I was told no that there was no
that further
questions osbor yeah I mean I was just
going to get in on the same topic here
if there these changes are so
significant uh I I was just wondering
why they weren't filed during
in my opinion they violate house rule
36e okay
they're the the subject of the bill a
lot of the contents of the bill are the
same as House Bill 593 two of the bills
two of the small pieces that I want to
break off are the same that they're not
changed the the structure of the bulk of
the bill is is somewhat changed
but I mean I I can get into the details
but if you really want but but basically
um what happens now in law is that um
the asset forfeiture case is a civil
case and the and the um there's an
underlying drug offense criminal case
all right the bill House Bill 593
combines those into one single criminal
case that's what caused problems for the
judiciary's computer system was having
these two kinds of things be under one
case so our new approach that we are
doing with
them keeps them
split but has a lot of timing aspects
that that
merges how they proceed and
so you know in my opinion it's it's
you know this is all the same subject
right I mean it's it's it's and so in my
opinion it does violate House Bill 36e
and in my opinion that's what you know
discussion and
um representative Lynn came to you know
support this request I don't know if you
not
speaker um it's it's helpful to have
some idea what we're talking about but
I'm I'm going to remind everybody that
we only discuss the reasons for the late
drafting or the difference you know the
departure for the rules we don't delve
into the underlying
context
Smith and if I understand correctly you
believed that you weren't going to be
able to get these submitted until you
came to our next
meeting yes
well I had experience with
OS turning down a request for for an LSR
on the basis of similarity with a
previous Bill and and in my opinion
those two were not at all similar and so
in this case I was certain that they
were going to find these similar right
so follow up follow up trying to help
so you you're you need the late drafting
because you wanted to come here first
because you believed that there was
going to be an issue and just wanted the
ruling body to deal with it yes thank
you
Senor
Weber but I am clear that you did not in
the first instance go to OS and ask them
if they would do that drafting or argue
with them as any number of people have
done this term and other terms about
whether their decision was appropriate
or
not I certainly did that in the case of
my other
Bill not with this bill no because in
again in my mind this one is much
others sen shot would a motion be an
order I'd move that we not Grant the
permission to file a late Bill if I just
speak proy to the motion with all due
respect to my friend from Epsom I hate
to set the president in this body that
we're allowing somebody to file a new
bill while the standing committee still
has possession of the old bill and has
an adjudication ated it or acted on it
and secondly i' as a member from um
cheser County said I'd rather see it go
back to uh OSS and file three separate
bills and let let OS and eventually
maybe the speaker make a decision if
there's enough changes to have it go
forward thank you Mr
Speaker further discussion I would just
second for for discussion the motion of
my friend from
discussion I just wanted to point out a
further inconsistency I mean one of the
concerns that was raised was this is a
matter of justice and they don't want to
wait until next year because it's a
matter of justice but on the same but
they're also arguing that they don't
want to do it quickly so
uh I think that gets us in a bit of a
bind and I I really think it's an awful
you if there's no further discussion
cour will call a
roll thank you Mr chairman the motion is
to deny the request representative
Packard yes representative shirtliff yes
representative Smith no Representative
nter no
representative
Osborne representative
Sweeney represent Wilhelm yes represent
excuse me represent Weber yes represent
Simpson
passes here recognized representative
luno
thank you very much Mr Speaker members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Dave luno uh representing the
people of AMAC County District 9 which
uh folks live in uh hopkington and Bo um
I'm uh I'm here this afternoon to um ask
the committee to approve the late filing
of a bill with the same language as
house bill
626 from this past um uh 2023 session
due to circumstances unforeseen prior to
the close of the filing period my
remarks um this afternoon are attended
to lay out the facts and the
justification behind this request for
background House Bill 626 for the most
part shifts administration of the
education Freedom account program from a
third party to the Department of
Education according to the Bill's docket
house bill 626 was introduced in the
2023 session and was referred to the
education committee on February 14th
2023 it came to the house floor with no
recommendation and was voted ought to
pass 183 to 180 and referred to the
finance
committee then on April 6
2023 the bill came back from the finance
committee and on the house floor a
motion of itl was adopted on a roll roll
call vote of 19 5 to 194 with the chair
speaker Packard participating by voting
yes on the itl
motion leading up to the LSR filing
period September 11 through 15 2023 I
had conversations with the ranking
member on education and leader Wilhelm
uh and was advised that I could not
refile this bill for the 2024 session
because house rules bar introduction of
legislation in the second year uh of a
session that was voted itl in the first
um in the first
year and that's where we thought the
story
ended but on September 18th 2023 3 days
after closing of the LSR filing period
the speaker's office received a letter
from the attorney general concluding
that house member uh that uh House
member and state state representative
Troy mner was not domiciled in the
district that he was elected to
represent at any time during the 2023
session in violation of State Statute
and the New Hampshire
Constitution so let's go back to the
disposition of House Bill
626 the it the itl vote back in April
was a roll call vote and representative
mner participated it participated in it
voting yes to the itl motion based on
the Attorney General's investigation
it's clear that rep M's vote was
illegitimate and without M's vote the
I'm here today to ask the committee to
allow for the late filing of an LSR with
the same language as House Bill 626 that
we're talking about with the effective
date adjusted by one year house rules
permit this committee to approve the
late filing and introduction of
legislation quote based on urgent or
compelling need or events unforeseen
prior to the filing deadline and it was
not known that the
disposition of H b626 was illegitimate
until after the close of the filing
period upon examination of The house's
votes uh from this year there were
likely many motions in which rep M's uh
vote affected the
outcome but in the case of House Bill
626 a roll call vote shows that R mner
specifically enabled an itl motion to be
adopted this is an important bill to
many members of the
House as its multiple strong votes
indicate had it been laid on the
table or otherwise stalled but not found
itl it would have been refiled for this
year clearly this is an event unforeseen
as the house did not know until the LSR
filing period was over that the
disposition of house bill 626's itl was
not legitimate and should not have
barred its filing for the 2024 session I
ask the rules to support the request for
late filing so that we can rectify the
bluno
okay if there no being no questions I'd
make a
motion I would move to allow for the
motion after the second count thank you
for finishing my sentence there I'll
second
it um Mr chairman uh first of all I
consider still today Troy Mard I think a
lot of us in this room do is a good
friend regardless of whatever happens to
him in the future but um I think on this
instance with this was a tie vote on the
motion to itl and his being not a
resident of his
district and if you can believe half of
what you read in the paper is the
comments made that he knew full well
that he wasn't supposed to vote that he
was not living in
Lancaster um I find I do find that
somewhat agreed just very much so and I
think he had an impact on the outcome of
this
vote and I would think under those
circumstances where the house was so
evenly divided on this question that to
allow the member to to file again under
these circumstances would be the
appropriate thing in the and in the best
interest of the house tradition of uh
fness and
uh right doing in all circumstances so
thank you Mr
Speaker F discussion sen
Smith thank you Mr
Speaker
so one that we think we know about I
don't know when representative murder
stop using the apartment in Lancaster I
don't know when representative hatch
moved to Bedford um a couple of years
ago I don't know when a representative
who moved out and then got elected in a
new District left they didn't resign in
the middle they were serving I'll use
the word that's been brought up
illegitimately unless they moved on
organization day we hear rumors about
these things all the time um so if I can
find one other representative serving
illegitimately do we then come back to
this body and undo this
vote I don't like the cycle of getting
into that and going back to try to find
ways to redo
it for other discussion Senator sh um GL
be it for me to disagree with my friend
from Charlestown but in this instance I
disagree with my friend from Charlestown
uh I think we do know from what the
attorney general has told but even more
we know from the comments made by
representative mner and the union leader
and other uh newspapers the fact that he
knew for six months that he was no
longer living at his residence uh the AG
said in their report that he had moved
out of uh Lancaster the apartment
building he had he just had an office
there but he was living in Carol in um
Coos County uh and that he had been out
of that district for quite some time as
far as my friend Bill hatch I know we
all know and we miss his service in this
house and on the finance committee we
know he has been ill for quite some time
of course he's been out of the district
he was in Connecticut for a while
because of his illness uh and knowing
Bill I know he's a man of ethics and
would not do anything
inappropriate contrary to the rules of
this body but I think in as far as Mr M
representative murer as I've said he
stated in the press that he was out of
this dist out of his district for six
months mon but the fact he mentioned
that other members of the House have
done the same thing and I think all of
in this room know that members of the
House have not done that same thing that
we take pride in representing at
districts and we've had members resigned
because they've moved one town over so
with all uh good faith and my friend
from Charleston I disagree with the
comment thank you Mr Speaker govern
wber thank you and following on from the
comments of my friend from
Penacook
um this is an extraordinary set of facts
in this case there and and the issues of
residence and domicile are difficult and
murky I know we had a member for example
whose house burned down and he could not
therefore live in the house that was not
there anymore and during the course of
rebuilding the house he stayed in place
that might not have been in his district
but his intent was always to return so
and intent
is a legal portion of the
inquiry um this case
is particularly clear in that the
representative himself made certain
allegations it's certain representations
at certain times that made things much
clearer than they are when somebody is
trying to deal with a difficult
situation we've always taken these
matters one at a time and looked at the
individual facts and I think we have in
the past made real accommodations for
people who were dealing with
difficulties of one sort or another the
other distinguishing factor of course is
that representative hatch was not here
to vote on anything so there's
not when he had already when he stated
that he had already when he later stated
that he had already moved so I I think
these should be taken one at a time I I
agree that they should not set a
precedent for every single thing but I
think that we have uh the the issue is
looking at each case individually and
this case uh is far more clear than many
of the other cases that we have seen
Smith so other things that I know
happened a recently not this term a
representative elected rolling around
New Hampshire for over a year without
estate plates because they had just
moved here so I would just ask you to
ask yourselves do you believe they were
serving him properly because they were
resident of another state or do you
believe that they were willfully
violating our Motor Vehicle Laws because
those are the only two
options there's a lot to look into in
these I agree with you but let's go back
to the procedure part of it can this not
be filed for 2025 is it that urgent is
there no bill sitting around that an
amendment could go on with a little
Artful authoring it's usually possible
to get what you want out of a bill
tagged on to another other one there
must be some other way to accomplish it
than for the rules committee to do this
essentially saying publicly that we're
undoing a vote on the house floor which
discussion hey the motion before us is
to accept the uh late filing cler will
call rooll Representative Packard no
representative Sheriff yes
representative Smith no Representative
nter no representative
Osborne representative Sweeney no
representative Wilhelm yes
representative Weber yes representative
five
Weber thank you Mr Speaker uh for the
record my name is Lucy Weber I represent
chesher 5 which is the Connecticut River
Town of um mple I'm sorry I have to
think a little hard I've represented 11
cheser County towns over the course of
my service
here so what I want to ask for the
permission to
draft um out untimely also arises out of
the issues surrounding the Attorney
General's letter that that was received
by the speaker on September
18th in that letter uh what I would like
to do is draft a bill so you know where
I'm going with this that would require
the Attorney General to notify the
house as soon as they get some kind of
confirmation that a member may be
sitting who is not residing in the
district where they're supposed to
be and I know that this has been raised
the problem was that representative mner
made represent present ations to the
Attorney General's office in May and the
letter did not come to the speaker until
September at during which time many
votes were taken which we all now view
with certain degrees of problem
problematical
anyway the what I am
proposing the Attorney General when when
people said why did you wait so long the
Attorney General responded that they did
not their office did not want to
compromise a criminal
investigation and if you recall the
letter from September 18th there was a
significant amount that had to do with
the membership in the house which the
Attorney General acknowledged was a
matter for us to consider but there was
also a significant amount of that letter
that had to do with their criminal
investigation and where it had arrived
and what I want to do is to try and
separate out very clearly those two
issues for the Attorney General's office
should this bizarre situation arise
again um and what I would like to do is
be able to draft a bill that requires
the Attorney General's
office when and and the actual wording
of the bill can be entirely up in the
air until it goes to a committee and and
is discussed
but I want this body to be notified as
soon as there
is a determination or possibly just
credible evidence and again that's to be
discussed later on about some knowledge
that the Attorney General's has about
somebody's residing elsewhere other than
where they were elected from and I want
to separate it out very narrowly because
I'm want to make it very clear that the
only thing we are asking to be informed
of is the residence issue which is only
for this house to
decide and
any issues other than that that may lead
to a criminal investigation would be
well
outside of anything that the Attorney
General is required to con convey to us
we certainly would respect their part of
the process just as I think they should
respect our part of the process so
that's my proposal for late
drafting again it you know it all arose
after the drafting period and and um I
would hope that what we would have is an
opportunity for the house to take a good
look at this situation in a public forum
and for the Attorney General also in a
public forum to have the opportunity to
discuss with us the concerns that they
have uh so that we could come up with
some uh clear and meaningful legislation
going forward as guidance as to whose
responsibilities are are which in this
issue that is so entangled with issues
of separation of powers so thank you for
your
consideration
SM thank you so I'm confused about what
it would actually do so allow me a
hypothetical and this is not based on
any actual person so a serving
representative who based on his tan and
social media post appears to live in
Florida I'm sorry if that resembles
anyone so I put in a request the
Attorney General to see if this wellan
and funloving individual is actually
living in Florida 80% of the time or as
a New Hampshire resident what happens
next well my understanding of residents
which dates from law school which I
intended in the late stone age uh
because I have avoided sitting on the
election law committee has an aspect of
intent and it's going to be an
individual inquiry in every single
single case but I think this is one of
the things that ought to be discussed
thoroughly in committee as to whether
the attorney general has a
responsibility to report to us only when
they have confirmed that the individual
is not living in their District or
whether they need to report to us when
there are concerns in your
hypothetical if there's stuff all over
the internet that could give rise to an
inquiry I think there's all kinds of
aspects we certainly had a case of a
representative who's reputed not to be
living in his district and uh that was
sent to the legislative Administration
committee which I believe actually voted
to recommend to the Full House that he
be removed from the
house and uh that recommendation should
have been taken up at the next house
session but because that member
presented to the then speaker a signed
lease uh that the then speaker decided
that that was mooded and I think that
that's an incorrect decision because I
don't think you get it's not a matter of
whether you get tagged off base the
Constitution doesn't give you a right to
cure the Constitution says when you
leave the seat is vacated and so my
argument that case would be um if if if
they don't have the backup they don't
have the backup and whatever you're
you're postulating is is also available
to everybody uh I certainly didn't have
any way of knowing where the
representative was was living or what
his living situation was and I think
that's something that ought to have been
communicated to the house and I think
that anytime we have that concern the
house can take it up as a matter of its
own responsibility and has the duty to
do
that uh because I think that is our duty
to make inquiry into those
situations uh but again this is a very
specific
situation and I think it would be
helpful to have a clearer delineation of
what the responsibilities are and as I
said I would I would draft a bill with
some selections that I might might make
but I would offer that entirely in the
spirit of having the house thoughtfully
and carefully deliberate with input from
everybody involved as to what the best
way of dealing with this kind of
again
senat thank you Mr Speaker as I
understand what you said what your bill
would do would require the Attorney
General once they real realize that a
member of the house is living somewhere
other than the district to notify the
speaker notify the
house that's correct I have do have a
concern with that and we know the
members of the House get in trouble and
I think our friend from Windam sitting
behind you was in the US attorney's
office when a majority leader from the
New Hampshire house was arrested on
federal charges if that had been a state
invested well I'm not going to mention
the name but it's on the plaque out in
the if you want to look at it on your
way out um if that had been a state
investigation and they were
investigating him on some of the
criminal offense and realize that uh he
was living somewhere else in the state
or somewhere else all together maybe
Florida um under this law they would be
required to notify the house that the
person was no longer living in the
district and therefore jeopardizing
their case by notifying their target
that they were investigating their
because that's how the information got
house well in the first place the the
bill that I was contemplating only spoke
to the Attorney General's office not to
Federal authorities the Attorney
General's office but I'm oh well you
spoke of a federal investigation and I'm
um there there isn't a need
to compromise a criminal investigation
because the only thing that needs to be
communicated to the house is the
fact of residents or non-residents not
anything
else and nobody has to discuss with the
house why they were investigating that
it could have been a complaint filed by
a constituent such as the town clerk
here uh and and the Attorney General's
office could make it very clear that
they were not going to discuss the
source of the complaint and I think
perhaps it would be a very good
suggestion for the bill that they not
under those circumstances discuss the
source of the complaint follow question
instead of a legis piece of legislation
could not the speaker off into into a
meming of understanding with the
attorney general that we be notified if
when they feel at an appropriate
time the the person has moved out of the
district if it comes to their attention
I can see where could jeopardize the
case if all of a sudden the speaker is
getting a letter from um the Attorney
General saying we know this person is
left and of course that person will turn
around and file Freedom of Information
Act uh saying where did you get this
information
possibly well I don't think that Freedom
of Information Act necessarily is going
to be successful because of certain
exceptions but this is why we don't go
into the underlying specifics of the
bill and my point would be I would like
to have the bill introduced and it may
be that upon introduction and after a
hearing and after
discussion it may be determined that
there is no way
to do that appropriately but I think
that the place to have that discussion
is out in the open with all of the
members of the New Hampshire house and
the public being able to
participate and
not in a closed memorandum between the
speaker and the Attorney General's
office because it is a matter that
affects all of us as house members and
all of the members of the public in
terms of representation so so as I say I
make
no representations about whether I would
even vote for the bill at the end of it
I may be
persuaded that there is no way to draft
such an issue but I think it ought to be
drafted I think it ought to be discussed
and I think that ought to be done by the
this house as a way of keeping its house
in order rather than by a memor random
of one person to the Attorney General's
office um so as I say I'm I'm I'm not
taking a position on how we would come
out on It ultimately it may be that
you're absolutely correct that we would
determine that there uh the risks would
be too great if there was a criminal
investigation but I think that's a
decision that the Full House ought to
make and that's why I'm asking that it
drafted further
discuss sen wman I just going to make
the motion to accept late drafting
second okay motion has been
discussion Willam thank you Mr Speaker I
appreciate uh the the the motion here uh
and and hopeful that this can be a a
bipartisan effort as we work its way
through the committee process into the
house floor um you know I think we know
that we have a constitutional
responsibility uh to make sure that our
members meet the
qualifications uh for office and uh
figuring out you
know what we can do moving forward uh to
maintain the Integrity of the
institution uh would go a long way
thanks further discussion sen of not
thank you Mr Speaker I was getting
confused and I'm trying to to wrap my
head around this because when you first
started talking it sounded to me like
you want people to be presumed guilty
until they're proven innocent but then
you said it it has to be investigated
first but that's what happened um I
wrote down you said something about may
they started investigating in May and it
was they came out with their letter in
September which is what happened so I
don't see the need for this right now
and I just don't feel comfortable voting
for
discussion General bosor uh yeah so I I
am
uh I don't imagine that this bill is
going to be able to go anywhere and be
able to overcome the objections that
representative brought forward but um
representative Weber did U very clearly
indicate why this was uh new information
had come to light and that uh there
could be um other circumstances that
this would affect over the next year and
so it is timely and uh it should be
discussion
I'll will be honest I'm conflicted
one I get I get what you're asking for
representative Weber
um I I'm just a little
concerned that
um going back to representative short
lft's
concerns that once that
letter came to us which was between 400
and 4:30 in the afternoon on
Monday um even though I was on the phone
first thing in the morning telling
representative we I representative mner
that he had to resign uh that letter was
out you know it was out there and all
the information was in
it and that that concerns me if there is
further criminal investigation in the
letter that you know was submitted to
us um and that's why I'm so
conflicted and may I answer
that yes
um here's the thing um there was no
necessity
for three and a half of those four
Pages all the Attorney General needed to
have said was Mr Speaker we became aware
on X date that this was a fact and in
that
case the representative had stated to
the attorney general where they was
living so it was not a near thing or a
question of intent or anything else he
stated that it was his intention to
finish out his term even though he
didn't live there and the Constitution
says you can't do that so the concerns
that you
expressed one of the reasons that I want
this drafted is to make it clear that
the Attorney General need not put all of
that into a letter I mean he did because
he wanted to make a particular case to
the house and that was his decision and
that was perfectly Fair what I want to
get at is the fact that that you acted
immediately after you received that
letter but the the
knowledge that he was not living in his
district was
available at a minimum in
May and you were not informed of it and
the house was not informed of it so it
was not available to be acted on
and as a result a member who had stated
that he was not
living in his district had voted
multiple times and that's something I
really want to avoid for us going
forward so all I'm trying to do is move
the notification
Point uh because you're absolutely right
once that letter was out there it was
out there but what I'm trying to do is
both limit what is in the not
notification to Simply the fact of where
the representative is
living and make sure that there isn't a
lapse of five months while a whole
investigation is going on during which
time somebody is voting without the
authority of the Constitution because
the Constitution says that your
representative ceases
immediately and so that Tim
flag is one that is
unconstitutional because in this case
just in this case it would be very
different in any other
case um the member was aware he may not
have been aware of the provisions of the
Constitution but the member was aware of
where he was living and and had a
particular view on it
so the reason that I think we ought to
have a buil to explore all of this is to
explore how to appropriately limit if
that is
possible a
notification to whom that notification
is sent to the speaker to the speaker
and the minority and the majority
leaders to the legislative
Administration committee um to the
entire house but I think those are
things that I would love to see
discussed in public public to see if we
can come to a reason
conclusion that would satisfy and
because this situation was allowed to
persist for a long time with people
knowing that something that was
violating our constitution on a regular
basis was happening and the house was
not
given that information to be able to
deal with it and you know maybe maybe
there were people who knew things and
should have talked to other members of
the house about them and you know that's
too bad
but I don't know anybody knew and I I
don't know who knew what and when and
and uh in other cases it has usually
happened in other cases when a member
hasn't been living in the district
somebody has made a complaint to us
rather than to the Attorney General's
office and the house has undertaken its
own investigation which is what the
house ought to be doing and I just want
to make sure that we can get that
information as quickly as humanly
possible and as I said it it may be that
this is something that we
decide is not something we can draft
around and and I'm perfectly okay with
that but I think I think I think it's a
matter that this house ought to take up
and then you know people can vote
however they they feel about the result
if if a committee is able to come up
with something that they feel is
appropriate then great if the committee
believes and the house believes that
this is in inexpedient to legislate we
have a vote for that um which is why I
want to see
Smith thank you Mr Speaker we're getting
way into the weeds of a bill that
doesn't
exist the the simple question is as my
friend from Walpole said why she needs
late drafting she did that satisfies me
this is a conversation that can happen
so I mean why
question l go call a roll the motion is
to allow late drafting represent
Packard yes representative shirtliff yes
representative Smith yes Representative
nder no representative
Osborne representative Sweeney yes
represent Wilhelm yes represent
Weber represent Simpson yes motion is
so see we've had such a good discussion
or yes
um when must I have something to OS
buy uh thank you representative
typically after this meeting I go over
to OS and inform them that uh that the
late draftings have been approved um
usually we don't have a steadfast rule
in this however usually we we try to do
it within a week or so oh absolutely
yeah thank
any is there any other business to come
before us just just to clarify Mr
Speaker does allow for late drafting it
it the same deadlines however for sign
offs do apply so that's uh and just a
quick reminder uh as we uh undertook in
our spring meeting um the late drafting
has already been approved uh by statuto
that represent
Smith thank you Mr
Speaker
so there have been questions in my short
tenure in the house of 12 or 13 years
about when part two article seven of the
Constitution applies that's the one
about not taking fees or acting as
counsel to advocate for a cause before
the
legislature it might interest you to
know that over a hundred years ago the
house had a rule defining this so that
we didn't actually have to fight with
each other about what it actually means
and whether or not some group paying you
a salary to then come here and file
bills for them qualifies I think it does
some disagree with me so what I would
ask is this is a solution that has to be
of the house and not a political fight
if there is any member of the other
party that would work with me on
drafting a rule such as this to uh the
old words from the early 1800s were be
fully
explanatory of Article 2 part 7 sadly we
don't have that rule anymore and then it
would have applied to lawyers and then
you know the that was their worst fear
then because they didn't know what
lobbyists were but yet here they are
sorry
guys so um you don't have to answer now
but it would be great if we could get a
bipartisan drafting of when part two
article 7 requires you to forfeit your
seat it's a very short article and that
is the penalty and I believe it I know
of at least three cases where it was
violated I mean we don't want to get to
the point right where the NRA or Planned
Parenthood or the New Hampshire
Municipal Association or anybody even if
it's a group we like decides it's a
really good business model so pay
someone a salary so they can come on in
here and file bills and be in inside the
house Advocate that should never happen
that's just my opinion so um I would ask
you to consider that thank you Mr
Speaker is there any other business that
come before
us
I